what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight endgame Theory video before I get
into the topic I just want to say the
next giveaway winner has been randomly
selected and I will announce your name
at the end of this video
there are still several seasons of the
Game of Thrones series left that I am
giving away so make sure you enter if
you want a chance to win that link will
be down in the description now let's get
started
in today's video I want to go over some
of the biggest theories that are still
remaining that have yet to be confirmed
or denied with only six episodes left
there isn't a whole lot of time for any
filler during the final episodes and
according to most of the cast members
they are saying each episode in season
eight will be monumental so I'm kind of
expecting a grand finale type season all
six remaining episodes will most likely
be pretty damn epic mixed in with some
heartbreak because I do think we will
lose over 50% of the characters during
those last few episodes the reason why I
want to talk about all of this is
because there are still some really good
theories out there that have not been
resolved one way or the other the weird
thing about some of these theories are
no one really knows the origin of them
everyone has heard of them but no one
really knows who created them and I want
your opinion on how you think season 8
will end and I'm not just talking about
the season 8 finale either but what I
mean is how the show and some of the
characters story arcs will end in
general kind of like cleganebowl this is
a theory that has been around for years
and depending on the outcome it could
seal the fate of one of or maybe even
both really big and popular characters
like the Hound in the mountain the hype
around this theory really started to
pick up during season six when the Hound
came back into the story after he was on
the verge of death after getting his ass
kicked by Brienne the Hound came back
and Cersei was on trial when a lot of
people assume Cersei would go at the
trial by combat and use the mountain as
her champion and then somehow the Hound
would end up being the champion for the
faith but it never happened and Cersei
decided to go with her own grand finale
instead but then in season 7 the hype
started to rumble again during the
meeting at the dragon pit because the
Hound finally confronted his brother and
he basically told him that he knew his
Judgment Day was coming but does this
mean we're gonna get clogged Ambo in
season 8 no it does not
but it is still on the table the hound
is on his way north where it will
basically be ground zero for the Great
War and there is no guarantee the Hound
will survive any battle against the dead
in the north while the mountain is still
chillin in King's Landing with Cersei
who has no intentions of coming north to
help them in any way in fact she has
more reinforcements coming to help
secure her position as the queen of the
Seven Kingdoms so do you think there is
still enough room in the story for them
to give us cleganebowl some people say
all Dan and Dave do these days is give
us fanservice so if that's the case then
we will most likely see all of the
popular theories come to fruition but I
don't think they're gonna do that and
give us everything we have all wanted
but on the other hand that doesn't mean
we won't get cleganebowl either in terms
of the overall story I don't think the
Hound and the mountain are very
important characters I don't think their
stories need to end in some epic fashion
but of course I would always recommend
it but regardless this is one of the
most popular theories out there the same
thing kind of goes for the valonqar
prophecy as well
millions of people believe this prophecy
will still come true even in the
television show where they chose to
leave this portion of the prophecy out
do any of you still believe this is how
Circe's story will end in the game of
Thrones
first you have to decide who you think
the valonqar is because that is still up
for debate for most people some say
Jaime Lannister is the valonqar while
others say Tyrion but then there are
people who believe the valonqar is Arya
Stark or even you're on Greyjoy as of
right now none of these characters are
really in position to kill Cersei Jaime
does have the best opportunity as of
right now because he is still right
outside of the city but Tyrion is on a
ship heading north
Euron is on a ship heading to Essos and
Arya is in Winterfell which is about to
be under attack very soon so unless
Cersei marches north with the Lannister
troops and the golden company that means
everyone else is going to have to defeat
the night king in his army first then
come back down to King's Landing to
finish off Cersei and her army there are
reports that say each episode in season
8 will be around 90 minutes long and if
that's the case then there are certainly
enough time to engage in several battles
or Wars across the entire continent
especially when most of the story
Lions are gonna all be taking place in
the same place we're not gonna have to
bounce around the ten different
locations to check in on each character
most of them will all be together now
which leaves more time to do other
things Cersei is one of the most
important characters in this show and
she is arguably the best actor on the
show so the way her story ends is going
to be very important in terms of the
entire series being looked at as a whole
if Cersei just dies in some random way I
think it would really affect the legacy
of her character I should say I am
stowing the camp that believes Cersei
will have a very personal death I think
she will be killed by someone who is
very close to her
most likely Jaime in the show but I
could also see Cersei surviving the
series being part of the bittersweet
ending as well everyone has been waiting
and wanting her to die but I wouldn't be
surprised if she somehow pulled through
and made it through the winter she has
proven herself to be extremely resilient
but then you have these theories that
more recently became very popular like
brains start being the night king once
again I think the night king is one of
the more important characters in this
series as well even though we barely
know anything about him the entire
series has been building towards this
inevitable war against the night king in
the way they end this part of the story
is also very important to the entire
show's legacy if they screw this up it
can hurt the entire show that's when you
have to ask yourself honestly would they
really in this series would brain stark
being the night king how would that
affect the way we look at all of the
events that have taken place would that
be the best way to tell his story by him
being the ultimate bad guy quote-unquote
the entire time if you're not very
familiar with this theory then you
should go and watch Game a series video
about the true identity of the night
king in my opinion he made the best
video about this theory I think he
presented some of the most believable
evidence in my opinion shortly after he
made his video everyone else started to
jump on this theory and it became kind
of annoying but I think Nexus video was
really well done there is definitely
enough evidence to support the theory
but like most theories there is also
evidence that supports otherwise the way
that I have seen this theory presented
does seem like an interesting way to cap
off the story of two characters at the
same time but I'm not so sure the show
is going to go in this direction
I am 100% confident brain will play a
huge role in defeating the night king
but I'm not personally confident and
saying brain is the night king although
I do like the theory there are also many
theories surrounding how the night king
is going to be defeated and where this
final battle is going to take place I
think this is one of the most important
aspects of how the story is going to end
this show was built on the politics and
relationships between all the main
players but there was always that
underlying threat which was the biggest
threat beyond the wall it just kind of
loomed over everything without ever
having to be at the forefront of the
story but it was always gonna be one of
the biggest parts of the story in the
end my personal belief is we will see a
few smaller battles in the far north
mostly just the night king and his army
destroying a few towns but ultimately I
think the battle and the night king will
end in Winterfell I think that's why a
stark must always remain in Winterfell
and I think that's why they always said
winter was coming in that's why that
particular castle is called Winterfell
itself that's where the king of winter
will fall like he did before many years
ago I believe it's all connected the
very first scene of this series was
beyond the wall where we got our first
look at the others then the very next
scene was in Winterfell what the Starks
I believe that's how it will ultimately
end with the others falling in
Winterfell but this is just my opinion
there are other theories out there that
have some interesting evidence as well
what state the night king will make it
much further south than Winterfell some
of this stems around the scene during
Danny's vision at the house of the
undying when she is standing in the
Great Hall with the roof completely
destroyed in the iron throne covered in
snow now obviously that could be seen as
a metaphor but personally I do believe
this was the scene of the future
it is finally snowing in King's Landing
which we all saw at the end of season
seven when Jaime Lannister was riding
north so you can only imagine how much
more snow will be in King's Landing by
the end of the season eight
I think Daenerys might actually be the
one who burns the Great Hall herself
when the final war against Cersei
happens but who really knows brain stark
also had a vision of a dragon flying
over the rooftops of King's Landing and
some believe this might be the night
king riding on Vasari on and he will be
the one to destroy the Great Hall
if you look at the rooftops in this
vision there isn't any snow on the roofs
and it's still very sunny out so I
highly doubt this is brand seeing the
night king flying over King's Landing I
do not believe that is how Game of
Thrones is going to end with the night
king making it that far south I know
some say there won't even be a huge war
on the end but there is actually going
to be another pact that takes place
where things will end with another type
of peace treaty between the humans and
the Inhumans
but I just don't see it ending that way
in the show I don't think HBO hired
Miguel supports Nick to direct several
episodes in the final season for it to
end without a huge war I think he's
gonna produce an absolute bloodbath but
what makes the most sense to you where
do you see the final war against the
night King taking place are you among
the camp who believe he will make it
through the north and all the way down
the King's Landing or the God's eye or
do you think he makes it even further
south than that are any of you willing
to double down and say the night King
wins in the end and everybody else dies
I know one of the most popular sayings
is all men must die but do you really
believe that will happen if the ending
is supposed to be bittersweet in the TV
series then how could they make an
ending with any kind of sweet if every
character dies and the night King lives
I just don't see that happening but I
want to talk about Jon and Daenerys too
because I think the way their stories
and are ultimately the most important
these are the two characters that we
have followed from day one and now that
they have not only risen to the top but
now their stories are intertwined in
every aspect they have always been the
key to how it was going to end and I
think just like was Cersei in the night
King if you screw up the ending of these
storylines it can hurt the entire legacy
of this series just keep in mind these
are my opinions because I'm sure there
are people who hate Cersei and Jon and
and Aris and don't give two shits about
how their stories end but I don't see
how you couldn't when you know the show
is gonna hinge on what happens with them
the big theory that revolves around Jon
and Daenerys both as the prince or
princess who was promised if you're a
fan of this show or a story then you
must have heard about this now and what
makes it an interesting theory is how
many characters actually fit the
description I have actually seen
theories that say Davos is the one and
guess what the evidence actually makes
sense although I don't believe it's true
but it kind of amazes me how one thing
can fit with so many different
people just like the valonqar theory
even if you don't believe in this theory
at all that I'm sure you can agree that
one of these characters will be looked
at as the bigger hero than the other or
the one who sacrificed the most for the
people when it's all said and done the
only problem is there will always be a
bias when it comes to these things if
you're a fan of one character more than
the other then you will usually say well
my favorite did more good than your
favorite and so on and so forth I have
always believed that someone will have
to sacrifice themselves in order to
defeat the knight King and I'm certainly
not the only one I'm sure many of us
believe this and John seems to be one of
the more likely candidates to step up
and do this considering he has shown
that he is willing to sacrifice himself
if he needs to most of you already know
my stance on a lot of this stuff
considering I've made videos on so many
different things
unless you're new here then you should
go back and check my catalog of videos
but there are just so many theories out
there that have yet to be resolved there
is a theory that says Arya Stark will
wear Jaime Lannister's face to kill
Cersei and there's a theory that says
Samwell Tarly is actually writing the
entire story and in the end he's
actually going to be reading the story
to baby Sam who I am assuming would be
much older by then but you get my point
which theories do you like and believe
will come to pass before this series
ends which theories that are out there
do you think can actually help tell the
ending of this series in a fitting way
that the majority of the fans would
accept I know it might be hard to choose
and there's so many that I didn't
mention but I just wanted to briefly go
over the main characters the two kings
and queens that I think are the most
important in terms of finishing this
series but let me know how you think
it's gonna end down in the comments I
would love to hear what you think
especially if you have something new and
refreshing to add before I go I want to
remind everyone that's starting this
Friday I will be live-streaming once a
week every Friday around 8 p.m. Eastern
Standard Time
these live streams will be patreon
exclusives for everyone who supports
this channel on patreon if you would
like to watch and chat with us during
the live streams you can find the link
to my patreon down in the description
but now it's time to announce the next
winner of my Game of Thrones series
giveaway there are seven seasons a game
of Thrones so far and I'm giving away
one season to seven different people so
farther has only been three winners so
there are still plenty of time to enter
to get your chance to win his season of
Game of Thrones that link to enter is
down in the description also but today's
winner is Cassio Lewis I don't want to
read your entire name because I know I'm
gonna butcher it so just make sure you
look at the screen now to see if that is
you from Brazil make sure you send me a
private youtube message or you can send
me an email and let me know what season
you want so far the first two winners
pick season 7 and season 6 so you can
have any other season you want good luck
to everyone else and thank you all for
watching
I really appreciate that and thank you
to all my new patreon supporters also
all of you have helped me out
tremendously and with your donations I
was able to buy one of the best
streaming laptops available so that
really means a lot to me in this channel
have a great day everyone I will see you
in the next one bye
[Music]
you
[Music]